all right that was uh part a 1a well
done if you got your way through that
let's have a look at part b together
which is a
pretty classic 3d vectors question it
says
where does the line are and then they
provide you all of this this particular
part
intersect the sphere and then they give
you this equation of a sphere down here
okay so what do we do with this thing
we're trying to find points of
intersection and just like in two
dimensions the way that you find points
of intersection is to solve
simultaneously it's not that complicated
right so let's have a go at doing that
together
to solve this is our part b
part b to solve simultaneously i'm going
to get the two equations together so i
had the line being equal to
i think was i plus 2 j minus 3 k
so there's our three directions there
here comes t so often we have a lambda
there but it doesn't matter the
parameter can be called anything
and then you've got
2i
plus j
plus 2
k
there's our straight line
our sphere is going to be r take away
and then this should look suspiciously
familiar to you
2 j minus 3 k you can see in fact that
matches the vector that you got up here
that positions the line
and what's that going to be equal to 6
so there's our radius of our sphere
so solving simultaneously as promised
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
substitute the line into the sphere
equation that looks like the most
straightforward way to do it
so solving simultaneously i'm going to
substitute all of this
r
yeah i'll just stay with orange that's
fine all of this r
into this r right here okay so therefore
i get
i plus 2 j minus 3 k
plus here comes the parameter t 2 i plus
j
plus 2 k
and then there's the there's the
substitution into r and what i subtract
is this same vector that i had here so
i'm going to subtract that and close off
my
absolute value that equals to 6.
so you can see here this is going to
cancel with all of this so that gives me
the absolute value stein starts again
you get that t in there and then you've
got in fact i don't know why i wrote
that separately all of this comes along
for the ride
close that and that equals to 6. all
right now this is the part i then need
to go and solve
i'm really looking for the values of the
parameter like particular values of the
parameter will get you onto particular
points on the line so there are going to
be i expect a couple of different places
that the line will intersect with the
sphere i'm just assuming that it's a
secant i may well find that there are no
points of intersection so there will be
no solution for t
or it is possible that this line is
tangent to the sphere which would mean
that there is a single value of t that
actually works so let's try and solve
this and see what emerges
i can get rid of all of this absolute
value notation or the altitude value
notation that is you know relevant to
get rid of by saying let's pull out the
parameter there t and then apply that
absolute value to this which is what's
the distance to the point at the end of
this position vector so this is just
pythagoras yeah it's going to be the
square root of
2 squared plus 1 squared plus 2 squared
i'm just reading off my i and j and k
coefficients right that's how far i'm
moving in the x the y and the z
directions
that is equal to 6
and then i just need to do a bit of
solving here so
this is going to be
absolute value of t over here
this is four plus one plus four so
that's nine so the square root of nine
last i checked it is three
that's equal to six so now i'm getting
the absolute value of t equals divided
through by three that gives me 2. so t
can be plus or minus 2. so what i need
to do is take these these two parameters
and pop them back into the line equation
because that's where t belongs right and
that should give me two coordinates two
points on the line that intersect with
the sphere
so substituting back
into the line equation
and i think it's really important
whenever you're working takes a sort of
left or a right turn you use words to
make clear why the equations or why why
one equation sort of gives way to
another one so substituting back into
line equation because that's the only
one that has t's in it
let's do t equals 2.
so t equals 2 is going to give me a
particular point i'm going to call it
0.1
and when i substitute in here is the
line equation right here so the t equals
2 is going to go right there yeah now
just to make this a bit easier for
myself i'm just going to write this in
column form because then i just don't
have to write all the i's in js and k's
and mathematicians famously lazy right
so here comes the column it's 1 2
negative 3 there's my position vector
and then i'm going to add 2 lots of you
know there's the parameter that i've
substituted in
2 1 2 there we go that's the direction
vector
so when i have a look at that let's see
here i'm going to compare my
components here so that's 1 plus 4 on
the top 2 plus 2 in the middle and
negative 3 plus 4 on the bottom so
that's giving me
5
4 and then 1 by the looks of things
done that for the first parameter let's
do it for the second so here comes
negative 2 that's going to give me a
secondary point and in fact it's going
to look much like this first piece of
working here if i can copy and paste it
properly this first piece of working
here with just this one subtle
difference which is that minus sign
right because i'm substituting in t
equals negative two and which means i
can be even lazier
joint mathematicians love
sort of saving the work everything here
is going to start out the same but
i'm going to be subtracting
this secondary vector here so it'll be 1
minus 4 2 minus 2 and then minus 3 minus
4. so i can just do the arithmetic on
this
let's see that's going to be a negative
3 you get a 0 and a negative 7 so that's
p2
and that was p1 up there so i'm pretty
much done i should tie this up neatly in
a bow because i was asked for points of
intersection not vectors that point at
points of intersection so therefore i'm
going to say the points
of intersection are and let's just write
them in coordinate form
r
we get 5 4 1 the first time wasn't it 5
comma 4 comma 1 and negative three comma
zero comma
negative seven
happy times okay so we have just found
the points of intersection between that
line and the sphere the next question is
going to be about integration